creams and masks lotions and potions
these elixirs weren't enough a YouTube
star Cassidy Valentine when she looked
in the mirror on the wall she wanted to
be transformed oh my god
Cassidy is a video blogger she's dealt
with depression and anxiety since her
early teens and during a difficult time
last year thought having lip fillers
would make her feel better while I was
having a procedure done I thought to
myself what am i doing why am I doing
this I wish that I had spoken to someone
before about what was going on because I
realized the midway through that I was
doing something really stupid I didn't
need to do honestly I did feel like it
would make me feel better but I didn't
it didn't do anything because it's up
here that I needed to fix until now most
of the concern about unregulated
cosmetic treatments is focused on when
they've gone wrong and that's what
happened to Cassidy who needed her
procedure corrected by doctors but the
NHS says practitioners also need to
consider people's mental health any
practitioner before they commence or
even agree to undertake a procedure
should do a proper assessment of the
person in front of them what is it
they're wanting to achieve have they had
procedures before what's their mood like
what is it they're hoping to gain the
aim is to try and bring some regulation
to an industry where a few rules exist
where anyone can buy and inject fillers
even if they've had no medical training
but is this guidance really just
preaching to the choir it was agreed
between the NHS and a voluntary group of
registered cosmetic practitioners many
of whom already carry out mental health
screening dr. T Ganesha was a medical
doctor before moving into cosmetics
he says the new guidance does nothing to
rein in unregistered practitioners I
don't think it changes anything for the
unregulated on
non medical practitioners and they're
not bound by anybody they don't have any
legal repercussions if things go wrong
and so these guidelines or suggestions
become law the UK aesthetics industry is
worth billions and with young people
bombarded with picture-perfect images on
social media and scrupulous
practitioners can make a huge profit by
exploiting those who feel unhappy with
who they are Caterina vut Otzi's Sky
News